olivia il y à des personnes solaire qui
ont le don d'attirer et d'entraîner les
autres par leur énergie
marielle de sarnez et est de ces êtres
rares c'est régulier profondément
originaux otilia marielle va nous
manquer parce que l'air de rien elle
nous a beaucoup donné
elle passait toujours pressés et laisser
derrière ces mots l'urgence à faire
l'erreur a corrigé le besoin d'aller
plus loin
sa rigueur exigeante nous a façonné
childéric son héritage ses convictions
continueront de faire battre le coeur
des démocrates
guy sa force démocrate sa lucidité
politique
l'indéfectible passion pour l'europe
qu'elle portait sa fidélité en amitié et
le courage qu'elle manifestait dans ces
combats était porteur d'espoir edwards
un grand merci madame pour un engagement
politique qui n'a jamais failli et des
convictions jamais trahi que les idées
d'une europe forte et prospère puisse
germer de tout le travail accompli
jusqu'ici
christine est là jusqu'au bout conserver
son regard bleu pétillant d'intelligence
de douceur caché derrière une carapace
de guerrière sa silhouette fine si
gracieuse
jusqu'au bout elle a gardé un esprit
acéré lucide sur l'état du monde et la
nécessité impérieuse de réveiller les
consciences discrète élégante combative
jamais d'apitoiement jamais de faiblesse
une ligne de winne est franche et
lumineuse une femme de combat une
centriste engagé une européenne
convaincue
jérémy nous lui devons tant que marielle
nous ait quittés semble inconcevable
absurde injuste
nous avions encore tellement à apprendre
d'elle rebecca son engagement ses idées
sa vision politique marqueurs ont
indéniablement la france et l'union
européenne
plus que jamais nous devons continuer de
porter ses convictions à l'heure où les
ronces prennent le dessus
la démocratie vient de perdre l'une de
ses plus belles fleurs